[Music]
[Music]
good
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
all right hey let me know if you don't
hear me i can turn myself up on my end
my settings got kind of messed up and
moving everything over
the bass is kind of like crazy right now
i don't know what that's about
you kind of sound like yeah you kind of
sound like you you're talking like real
like extra like like like you you you
trying to intentionally make your voice
get deep you know what i'm saying
i didn't test those settings at all
yeah it kind of just feels like a little
too strong if that makes sense
uh
let me make sure that
twitch is working because
sometimes twitch don't be working like
it's the only website that i don't
understand
okay it does
but sometimes like there would be
certain like twitch channels that i i
literally just doesn't work i don't know
what it is
but what up yo hey uh y'all let me know
how i sound now you're coming down a
little bit but you started shout better
um
okay so i just the right thing now hold
on
what's going on guys
so this is how we're gonna do this um
you have to excuse me i'll show you guys
um
i've been stuck at work the past two
days like three or four hours after work
um i saw people talking about triangle
strategy uh as you can see
let me switch uh transition real quick
uh that's what i've been playing i've
been playing triangle strategy so uh
okay
how was it
why is it showing that it shouldn't be
showing that
plus it was a little boosted
not bad though
yeah
you're a little boosted i don't know
what what
it is
i think i saw the issue i should be cool
now i should sound normal now i think i
saw the issue though you still sound a
little bit boosted
it sounds like you really trying to get
your point across today
nah so we'll be heard today
i'm making changes on the fly so y'all
let me know
on my um little dbs thing
i'm so tired i don't know why i really
wish i could have put a green screen up
or something man but
this is
that's kind of crazy i got the camera
kind of far away too
i'm going to get a close-up hold on
yeah maybe just turn yourself down a
little bit maybe that will solve
everything just turn yourself down a
little bit
i think it's just
because uh it's a reaction so i don't
really
expect a whole whole lot of people to
show up for this but
um how about now it should be cool now
yeah yeah you're fine i'll just turn it
down manually here too so
i think i uh was turned up too much on
my mixer itself
yeah you sound you sound better you
definitely sound better
so man i just don't know yeah yeah you
sound good so
all right what
what
yeah yeah flame uh
it's right here
triangle strategy i don't know
the uh
you guys know how these cameras are they
want to focus on everything but what i
tell them to focus on
but
yeah so so
hustle what do you expect from this
reaction
keep in mind they didn't like really
promote this as like an indie showcase
or anything like this now i don't i
think it's fair
to not expect like crazy stuff here like
no god of war is gonna be here
nothing like that but what do you expect
here
well i i do got a couple of sources or a
couple of people who i go to for the
playstation stuff um shout out to jack
moon johnny he actually said i think
it's supposed to revolve around
playstation japan um
i don't expect to see no blood borne two
i don't expect to see
no last of us two um no god of war as
you mentioned this is gonna be something
light um and i'm gonna be right with you
i didn't even know
this was happening this week until you
told me like yesterday i think you hit
me up about it he was like hey hustler
you wanna do i'm like
that that's happening now i'm like all
right cool i'll be here
i'll make sure i'm here but yeah i
didn't even know what was going on this
week they didn't really promote it as
per usual or as much as the
playstation didn't promote this is like
they would normally promote something so
i don't expect really anything honestly
i don't expect nothing nothing that's a
bad thing but i don't expect nothing for
real i it wouldn't surprise me if they
showed mostly empty stuff i'll just say
that
so what what do you think about um
about like a final fantasy in here
somewhere
oh no sir because i think i think if we
see something that big i think we'll
we would have got like word on that
matter of fact we would have got word
from square on that um
did they announce um the playstation or
the square announced the uh delay of
forsaken forespoken pardon me
yes
it's officially been delayed
all right so we won't hit nothing from
that either as a matter of fact so i
don't think we see game play from that
yeah i think this is gonna be super late
i won't be surprised if
excuse me i would be surprised if
something else is there let me cut this
up a little bit yeah we'll we'll talk
about uh
we'll talk about
her uh we'll talk we got some i got some
topics
uh for us to talk about after this thing
because it's only 20 minutes long but i
figured it'd be a good thing to start
the show with so
talk about some
some some halo then we're going to talk
about some some xbox one and 2021
metacritic average
first time it's ever been above an 85
hustle
um
then uh
then we're gonna talk about forsaken
getting delayed because that's just how
we are so well spoken uh yeah that that
yeah that's a little different hey um
with a few minutes left before we get
started with this playstation stuff
um do you expect to see anything at all
like what do you expect to see what
would you like to see i guess maybe well
i mean you you've ruined my whole
expectations in this thing i expected at
least some final fantasy they saying
japanese related stuff so now i'm just
like i could have stayed asleep man i
could have cancelled out a show entirely
this week like we could have been great
persona 6 or final fantasy 16 or bust
you know what dark times i'm right there
with you i go in you know what's funny
people always say keep your expectations
with with xbox but don't keep your
expectation of playstation i'm just
keeping that same energy i expect the
world from playstation the the winning
platform i want to see everything from
them
i see ghost wire tokyo in the chat
yeah sure why not
i'm not really interested in
the bioshop type games but yeah sure
well ghost tokyo is already
in the hands of reviewers so i don't
think that's gonna be here
okay
and i know that because i'm trying to
get a review code so
i don't even know why part of me feels
like i'm just gonna drop that game but
you know it is what it is i need to i
need to stick
to triangle strategy and get that
reviewed
uh
so far so so good man so far so good you
could tell it's like one of those games
hustle where it's like
you could tell that some some serious
stuff went down in the past
and you could tell the the whole world's
moved on from it and everyone acting all
nice to each other like because there's
these three kingdoms and they used to
have serious beef but now they're trying
to
now they work together and the whole
time i'm doing like these royal meetings
and stuff the only thing i'm thinking
myself is
someone about to stab someone in the
back like
someone this could be some game of
thrones stuff something about to go down
okay all right
well
that's good to know i i think the next
well i'm gonna get back on um i'm gonna
say demon souls i'm getting back on um
what's that
the souls born game that every elder
ring
that's why i was trying to get my stream
stuff together yeah i uh i i i'm
like 100 a level 115 or 20 and jesus
don't do that
yeah i got i got a samurai build
got the the moonville and i got the uh
the blood river of blood or whatever
it's called it's two katanas
so what i do is i switch
i switch to two
because i normally two hand them
so i'll keep them but like i'll hit you
with both of them because they have both
bleeding effects
but if i really need like a specific
type of ability i'll two hand one or two
hand the other you know what i'm saying
uh we've got five before we get started
oh go ahead we gotta five dollar
wanted to show my support to addington
hustle god bless guys and i hope sony
shows good stuff i agree man we need a
dre we we do we need a bloodborne and a
dragon a legend a dragon i expect all
that from this i'm gonna i'm going in
here with everything i got we need it
all
give me a reason to turn this
playstation on please playstation legend
the dragon all right y'all got it
the playstation
what's funny is the playstation is that
my girlfriend she plays that i don't
even play it so give me a reason to use
that man
um
okay here we go here we go
all right
the year 2043.
i think we've seen this game before
dinosaur forecast a dinosaur outbreak
will soon occur
this is anthem 2.0 and a team of exo
fighters
i hope not no i don't think it's anthem
i was like is it like someone trying to
do anthem better
wow okay
if we did see this i don't remember
capcom
wait is this
pragmatic
project pragmata or something like that
i don't know
capcom has really ran out of stuff to do
over there
they they hold up they really
make it
they're making a game about dinosaurs
and not the game about dinosaurs that
everybody wants with dino crisis
oh it is that can you just switch
echo
[Music]
suits and mid gameplay
that's cool
you know it's funny i talk all this snap
i'll probably go into playing this game
at some point
i mean but y'all play this kind of
reminds me of like a destiny type thing
the way is pve don't you dare say that
uh uh here we go
what the hell
exo primo okay all right i don't think i
don't remember that
another exo fighter recruit right
welcome to ivy yeah i don't remember
saying this at all
hmm
all right
i think everyone could have lived
without that play returns with more
announcements and updates for your
favorite game we will see we'll see how
good it is i'm not gonna yeah that's new
i'm not gonna go too much into it
because it looks like something new it
hits ps4 yeah there's no they just they
just said it was new
don't swat tokyo somebody in the chat
called that shout out to y'all
i do like the way they do these state of
plays
yeah they kind of just get to her right
you know you know no it don't sound like
it's no filler
oh ghost sorry tokyo is here
yeah
am i ahead of you at it
it just showed up
oh yes i am okay i'm ahead of you how
how much ahead
okay okay now we're cooking
you'll you'll see that in a minute yeah
i'm ahead of you i'm a chill i'm a jail
this ghost wire looks interesting a
little bit
like i'm not completely sold on it but
it does look interesting
i pass on that
oh you can't be like that man
i don't know
maybe it's the first person that got a
guy get over that i guess
that's that playstation stuff in you
talking man
not everything got to be third person
hunt for the truth
oh that's creepy
i think uh
i don't know i'm kind of half in half
out with that title i'm not gonna lie a
little half in half out i'm not gonna
say it's bad or anything like that i
mean i didn't really the dinosaur thing
what didn't look bad i was just joking
it's like a devil may cry rip-off
what's this final fantasy game yeah it's
our final fantasy game
well hell i was wrong about something i
was wrong about part of this
i found the fact that you see origin
okay
[Music]
later today visit playstation store
today that's on xbox by the way of
paradise final fantasy origin
now let's jump into i'm surprised
they're showing this with some all new
gameplay
all new
show gameplay something because i seen
one thing about this game that makes me
want to buy it
yeah and uh everything here wants to
kill you kind of way really surprising
sean since they just delayed it
to october didn't it i think so yes i
thought that's what i read on sweater
yo why are people so
down on this game
it just doesn't look good to me man
like the only thing i ever see is just
her walking through fields and shooting
stuff like there's never anything story
narrative in these trailers never
anything showing why is she doing
anything
never anything like remotely interesting
about it
well wait a minute there was a one
just her walking through streets and
shooting stuff russell the same stuff
we've seen
no no no no she was in the courtroom or
something like that and she was like
a defendant or something i remember
at one of these reactions that we did it
was it was adamant last year sometimes
this is a prime example scorings can't
get their stuff together
let's finish this
well i'm gonna try this one for sure
whether it's on pc ps5 whatever i'm
gonna try this one for sure i'ma wait
for that game pass
oh man
oh man
let's see if they put the date on this
thing yep october 11th there we go
all right well i'll play that day one
for sure i mean i'm probably gonna play
day one because i'm gonna review it but
still sprawling ps5 adventure for spoken
from luminous productions
i just want i hope it's good
gundam evol evolution
these are these playstation
games of service that you guys wanted
oh no
you know what i'll check it out but i'm
i'm
what is this
like mobile suit gundam but i never
really been in the end of this nowhere
welcome to the battlefield
three competitions game mode
are they trying to make a gundam
battlefield
this looks
this looks horrible
i'm lying with it i'm fine with it it
depends on how many game modes that
they'll have i know they if they are not
small this looks horrible
you mean graphically or just in general
i think i think i'd rather i think i'd
rather play solitaire on my computer
oh so come on it it's not it don't look
that bad do it
it looked pretty bad
well i can't say this until uh let's
lastly try to show but
it seemed like
the weapons it seemed like there's no
weight to what you're doing they just
don't look like it's not for me that
game's definitely not for me
put it on playstation now and i'll try
network tests oh okay they got a network
test coming out later on this year
oh let's go
let's go
oh okay so they're repackaging the game
but i want to hear about shredders
revenge for real for real
cause i got a couple of them games on
that list as you know addict
i feel like i can just go back there
behind my green screen and go to sleep
oh tournament fight it's okay hi
tournament fighters tournament fighters
was kind of ass back in the day but open
watch my life watch my language
tournament fighters wasn't that good but
they got they got a few gems in there
they got a few more gems in there
turtles in town
showed us the arcade game okay
it looked like these are the
are they getting full players to all of
this
i don't know
i i think
i think they are yeah i think they're
adding four players to i'm gonna i'm
gonna need the chat
to double check all these on twitter and
make sure all these are playstation
this is that one game i know what this
is i played the first one
what is this
um
i can't remember what it's called but
it's a fun game i mean i can't say it's
horrible or anything like that
look i can't speak for you on the chat
but i'm getting that kyle bunga
collection day one i'm sorry i got to do
it i got the gigabash i don't know if
that was the game i was thinking about
kaiju brawler gigabash comes to ps4 and
ps5 kaiju brawler gigabash
next a fan favorite fighting game makes
a beautiful and bizarre returns it's
sitting on the bottom straight fighters
is this street fighter 6
not actual game play don't you love when
they put that at the bottom
oh indeed at least they're not alive
this isn't street fighter because it's a
different art style
it might not it might be street fighter
anyway because it looks like it's going
to be a cgi
[Music]
i don't know about haddad fighters
all right in terms of graphically it'll
look fabulous i can remaster it and put
it back out it still won't look good
i know what it is i just got to
spoil on twitter i'm not gonna say what
it is is it jojo
yes yes you figured it out someone in
the chat said it
okay shout out to them yeah um never
tweeted that out but
the game visually looks good and they
can remaster this about 10 years from
now and it'll look even better like it
won't it won't age at all with 50
playable goddamn all right
okay
early fall 2b continued
all right well we got like what six
minutes left our next two games will
take you beyond life
well they showed the ninja turtles i'm
cool i like it 10 out of 10 for me let's
go
i just don't know jojo
oh [ __ ]
this is another seafood esque type of
trek to yummy
you're a little behind on your stream i
know
that is what it is okay okay
am i spoiling it or yeah you spoiled the
name but i wouldn't have cared
this isn't that this is game isn't all
that
it looked cool man it looked like it's
just gonna be a black and white too
you know what flame i want to go back
and play
triangle strategy
oh come on
it's not that bad yeah
it's it's pretty bad it's pretty bad
well they said they wasn't going to have
nothing left this state of play has
probably been one of the worst state of
plays in a while
but look they said they wasn't going to
show nothing big even though this this
game they're showing now well i mean
they didn't they didn't show nothing at
all so nothing big definitely what's
going to happen
they showed the ninja turtles so eddie
that can't let you do that show like a
15 year old game they showed something i
got you no no i had it 20 20 20 plus 24.
the volvo did you do oh you know what i
can trust this game now because the
volvo digital does have a good idea yeah
they they kind of tried to do it a
little bit
when it comes to indie games unless like
it looks really really good
oh [ __ ]
trapped
in an endless cycle
oh okay dlc for eternal
dying
y'all got it returning
always the same
damn looked really good even though it
was at 1080p games still look good
i'm not alone oh [ __ ] okay
oh you can play cool
i can get some help thank you
okay
okay this this is fun this is good
all right all right that's that's what's
up that's what's up
thank you thank you thank you
playstation
that was good that was good
hey i can actually get kids smooth
through the game now
hey facts
that's that's though that's dope this is
good this is good i like that that was
good infinite i didn't
i didn't beat this but they are they
adding stuff to the store
because that's what it looked like it
looked like some new story beats to this
too y'all let me know when i beat it
my release is within this tower
and i will find it
looks i saw the ending another the
ending was kind of like open-ended you
kind of interpret it how you will
but it sounds like they bought the
okay and it sounded like it's a free
update
all right march 22nd it's coming it's
around the corner too
house mark is bringing campaign co-op
and oh they got a survival mode to
return this campaign co-op
i like that
i need help boy
it's almost time to start off but before
we do let's get a first look at two
brand new games coming from square enix
two brand new games coming from square
enix watch they mess this up
when you are certain that what we are
doing is best for the people of the
kingdom
yes
i suppose it would in a sense
true
hey it can't be return it's not return
of director's cut it's a free update we
can't really go too much at them over
there
that's good it's free by the look of
the era it myths gives way to an era of
great turmoil kind of
the
gamepl
of alatane it's because they
that's because you need a you need boats
to attack them they're in the middle of
the ocean
we've finally been called in
[Music]
how do you think this looks at it
it depends what kind of gameplay it is
before i
i got to see the game play first
hey that's all you added i'm gonna need
that review sir
i don't know
hey with the show the show's about to
end y'all which i think of the show on
the chat how to tell that looks okay i
just gotta see more of it what should we
do now
we're going to retake it
this is our chance where they're all
assembled
we should send our best and crush them
that's right all the more reason to
avoid bloodshed
it also likely means that we're in
danger
i suppose it is the only way for us to
survive
oh here we go
the deal fields
wait chronicle
okay yeah
coming 2022
so hey hey
does someone look up on twitter tell me
if that's coming to xbox man someone
look up on twitter it is say only on
playstation so you know there's a chance
it might come on xbox
probably not probably on pc but
hey this kind of looks like valkyria
chronicles that that our chest well i
don't know if it's cell shader but that
that's that all style i'm not saying
that's what this is but
you know
kind of gives it all there
what is this
a big miss that's what this is
i won't go that far i won't go that far
i'll say right up my alley in terms of
third person over the i'm not over the
shoulder but third person action i'm
i could try to get get in front of that
rather pull my teeth out oh you got it
i think i'm more likely to get this to
chance than the last game
i think i'd rather give the last game a
chance than this one
become my tool of intervention
and save this world
they got like 10 people in a basement
making this game
yo come on man
oh it's you know we'll have to see how
it is though
i just don't like the aesthetics like
i think that they would have to grow me
a little bit because it's kind of
realistic getting kind of cell shaded a
little bit i might be here for that i
might be here for that
no this actually doesn't look bad though
like oh i said valkyrie chronicles this
is valkyrie elysium yes evacuary
elizabeth oh see valkyrie was good
because of the strategy in it now they
done
messed it up man they made it for me
i'm cool with that i'm cool man you got
plenty of games that are tied to you
yeah but there's a reason why they keep
making them like this
look at that dragoon wannabe
that's all for today all right well let
me go ahead and close this on this piece
that's all for today
all right we out um that's all for today
i'm not really mad at that um
the ninja turtles thing kind of pushed
it over for me
if i'm going to grade this and i know
people are going to
i see i killed them in jordan already
i'm gonna say seven out of ten but
that's only because nostalgia kind of
kicked in for me and um i like the last
game they show and it was one of the
other ones they showed to so few games
was cool you guys was cool
lord that mercy was it that bad they all
get lowered i gave it a 7 out of 10. it
wasn't that
it wasn't that bad
it was passable passable great man
passable great well i wanted to chat
tell me
how you feel this should have been man
put put a one through ten one through
three means god awful three through five
means i should have stayed home
uh five through seven means okay and
seven through ten means spentacular
tell me what you guys think man put it
in there
and it can't be your scale it's got to
be my scale keep that in mind i told you
the scale it's not your scale it's my
skill seven you're crazy i look like i i
make a lot of jokes the games looked
interesting it's just i got to see more
on most of them it it it wasn't like a
bunch of games i would not be interested
in whatsoever
but uh they they definitely need they
they needed more
better
shows and examples of gameplay when it
comes to those games
well the predictional theory quote
unquote that i had it was fairly right
in the beginning they said it wasn't
going to show nothing jaw-dropping which
we figured i'm surprised they showed a
first poker i'm surprised they showed
that think every date so october 11th if
i remember right um so we'll get that
then and that looks cool to me like that
that's that's something that i'll i'm
looking forward to trying now it should
have showed something no man some final
fantasies
something man well you know we've went
like a year and a half without seeing
final fantasy 16 hustle well listen
listen squares told you you know hold
your horses a little bit hold on to what
we got right here you know i'm going to
issue with it man
clearly i don't find a fantasy i feel
like scoring is starting to turn into
the platinum games of the industry man
they working on so many games and now we
ain't getting the one we want like final
fantasy 16 is becoming the bayonetta 3.
it is it's like we don't see it we don't
they don't talk about it i mean i think
we just recently saw something on
bayonetta like just not too long ago but
it's just like i can't say this is a
horrible study to play but it was just
like
for for for a japanese show
it could have been better
okay i see this 200 of y'all in here can
y'all please hit that like button and
share the stream out man um also i see a
lot of the scores in the chat
they're right they're right scorers
these these are my peoples man they
write
i was going to say look i respect your
opinion and i see why y'all if you
listen to hustle's voice he don't
respect your opinion
of course i do but no my my thing with
that was i was a little um
i mean look i didn't expect much so
i think i you know my expectations were
tempered you know so obviously yeah so
whatever they showed me was kind of cool
i'm a little upset we didn't see um not
that we would see it here but they did
show the ninja turtles cowboy collection
i want to see shredders revenge
what is that called
uh teenage mutant ninja turtles uh
shredders revenge
i thought you said the cowbunga
collection
well that's that's what what they showed
today was the cowbunker collection with
all those old retro games i'm confident
that they won by the way um
i agree
but we didn't see yeah i mean return
definitely uh carried the the show i
don't know there was a couple i i really
uh was interested in the
the kind of like strategy game that was
in there somewhere i can't really like
say it it interested me 100 but it was
something that i looked at now i don't
like
the hack and slash games so a lot of
that was hack and slash so
none of that really applied to me i've
never really been like the only hack and
slash i've semi enjoyed is devil may cry
and that's because i really enjoy the
universe they've built in devil may cry
but
as you've seen
through a lot that we we could easily go
and
just look stuff like that up so we don't
necessarily have to to play that
well
well
you know what
seven out of ten for me
seven out of ten yeah yeah
and that's just based off of
i mean i saw some things that i liked in
there the return on thing was really
dope though because i still got well i
don't have it next to me now but i still
have it i still had that game i was like
i'm glad that they added that update
because
i promise i need some help y'all one of
y'all going to carry me all the way
through this that's all i'm saying just
carrying me through the bosses i wonder
if it's going to be like a elder ring
type of thing the way you have to first
play it build the materials and then
call in for the co-op it's just going to
be drop and drop out i wonder how that's
going to work
hopefully it's not like eldon ring
though
elder ring
look we could talk about ring real quick
let's let's let's okay so we we've we've
officially moved on with the state of
play
now uh
how about playstation
it was okay it was okay
like
i can't can't go anymore i can't give it
any anything more than that but let's
talk about eldon ring
hustle
from someone such as yourself that's
been kind of
i wouldn't say necessarily hating on the
from software games but you've been
distant we'll say distance
you pop in every now and then we got a
two dollar super chat from flame
returner got co-op before halo i'm dead
oh he kind of right there he kind of
right there but i would say it's
probably a lot easier i don't
see but if you look at that
it looked like co-op was available in
this new mode it didn't look like you
could play it in the real
returnal game yeah
you just say he raised a good point
though you know
it's definitely it's definitely a bad
book
so all right
yeah what's up elden ring
how you feel about it
it's fun um i had the chance to stream
at the data that came out um i put the
60 down i'm playing it on pc
i do want to talk about some of the
technical issues first before i even get
into it the micro stutters kind of took
me out of that a little bit um
i'm running that on pc i have a fairly
decent pc
those micro stutters man um outside of
that outside of that what i like about
that game but i've always liked about
the the souls games in particular is the
character design well not the character
design but the enemy design um
you fight the one big brolic dude
standing up on the mountain he's like i
guess he's a mini boss or whatever the
case may be before you get cause i'm at
my group right now
i met my greek addict and um erica and
uh eric empire a couple of people tried
to help me with it but um it's fun um i
have to read well not read but i have to
like learn everything what seems like
for the first time because this is this
is like sakura
like i can actually if i really want to
i'm level now now if i really want to go
back to like that first area i can go
back in their farm if i want to beat
that dude with the big giant sword um
he'll drop so many wizard rooms right
he'll drop so many rooms and i can
really like you know beef up if i really
want to
i'm going to stream this game saturday
saturday probably saturday night and
what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna play it
at level nine to see if i can beat it in
that probably won't be able to but we'll
see um i'm the prisoner bill which is
like the
the magic
or the mage of the game and everything
explain to me how a prisoner gets access
to be able to use spells and stuff
got me
that kind of like doesn't make sense to
me like he's a prisoner so he knows how
to like
shoot spells one would think that like
a pray because
you would think that that kind of class
would be
something that maybe is like a stealth
type of class or something like i don't
know like prisoner that shoots magic
i mean to be honest all of these classes
don't really you don't really have to
abide by any of them you could do
anything you want
but it's it's it's interesting uh so
how
how far have you gotten it without like
spoiling too much like how far have you
got i'm not i said it no i met uh
margaret
i'm i'm right there like the part where
you um because i was streaming at the
part where you jumped in on my stream
and um erica was there and she was
trying to help me and we had the mpc
i'm right there i haven't played it
since then because you know i had some
personal stuff but i'm gonna pick it
back up friday on saturday man
here goes nothing i'll watch what i
think it goes nothing yeah yeah oh man
i'm gonna need all that i'm gonna need
all the help i can get but um
i love like the community like souls
like you know for the most part they're
like super accepting they're extremely
helpful and that ain't just erica that's
that's a ton of other people who i see i
see people posting videos of like
fighting different bosses uh parallax
stellar the girl over there stella over
there yeah i know she's posting those
videos erica congratulations to her
she's post posting those videos as well
so you know
i look i'm gonna use those videos to my
benefit i'm gonna get a little help but
i'm at least try to boss before i like
just go look it up first though but it's
fun and i've always enjoyed the
character design too like and that's
that's one of the things that i'm always
going to like harping back to
i like what they doing over there from
man and um real quick i didn't want to
bring this up i saw a stat the way it
was like a million people playing it at
once on steam and that and i don't
really be playing on steam like that
because of the because of all the
the cheating and fiasco stuff going on
there but um the way that
i see it that's huge to have that many
people playing that game like
because a lot of people don't really
gravitate towards
yeah because the pc the the problem with
the pc in terms of releasing games on
there it's a lot of options so people
will end up like leaving prematurely a
lot of the times but it does feel like
that
that isn't the case this time and we've
seen a lot of people stay so that that's
nice that's nice that we're seeing that
i think the turning point
for a lot of people
was bloodborne to be honest with you i
think that was like the turning point
when it comes to souls games when
when
um bloodborne dropped on ps4 i mean i
played it but a good buddy of mine he
had it he was like say ricky go ahead
and play this i'm like alright i just
wasn't i really wasn't into it i didn't
really know what i was doing either but
i think that was just like kind of like
the turning point to where
those souls types of games we used to be
intimidating to a lot of people
i think that that appeal is gone um i
don't know if you saw that but um did
you see the announcement that was made i
think it was made on twitter or might
have been made the news outlet they said
pretty much our games are going to be
difficult and they're going to remain
that way did you see that yeah
and i'm glad for that because i do feel
like
when it comes to from software games i
understand i personally don't care if
they put easy mode in that game i don't
care uh because i as long as it doesn't
affect the overall experience when you
first play it it doesn't matter to me if
it's easy or not as long as they make
the base
level
like difficulty that they've always made
and they down scale that i'm okay with
that but don't do it the other way
around
do not
like make the look make do not make the
easiest mode and then upscale it up
because i feel like then
you're not really making the game around
that difficulty you're you're you're
making it around the other difficulty
and you're scaling it up so as long as
they make it the difficulty that i'm
used to and they scale that down i'm
fine with that uh but you know here's
the thing like
sometimes games are just not for you
and i think that people
people forget about that i think people
have this
absurd motion that everything's got to
be for everyone and i and i just don't
think that's the realm of realistic [ __ ]
i don't think that's it like no like if
some games aren't for you and i think
until people really accept that it's
going to be kind of rough for people you
know what i'm saying because they always
expect
every game to be for everyone and that's
just not realistic
right um i mean i feel like it's a lot
of people in the industry complaining
about that i haven't i have yet to hear
uh i'm saying
i just i have you have to hear like an
average consumer say you know how come
this isn't like this i i haven't really
heard that like at all to be honest with
you so yeah you know and it's okay for
not to be for you it's okay for you to
sit this one out or sit whatever
conversation you want to sit out that's
cool
um
i saw
other rumblings around about people i
guess shaming or trying to get keep uh
ellen ring now it's like if you're new
to it you can't come or you can't be
around i'm like yeah y'all chill too
because
i mean hell i'm gonna try to join out
and i'm gonna get my 60 worth up out of
it if i play something for 20 hours i
can't get past the first boss first of
all i'm getting some help second of all
i'm enjoying it the way i want to enjoy
it but it's cool man like i feel like
you know what most most actual
communities pc community
xbox playstation what have you right you
know a lot of people are like really
inviting but it's something it's the
vocal minority who who are you know but
yeah what are they
they're what it is i mean
yeah
it's just one of those things that i
agree with you we need to stop telling
people how to play their games like i
see people attacking for using mage
builds
people attacking for all kinds of stuff
and it's just like people attacking
smooth because i jumped in there helped
them for balls or two it's like if you
don't get that nonsense up out of here
like first off smooth bought the game
like here's my thing hustle if if
someone like smooth is investing into
eldon ring and he's buying the game and
he's enjoying it then he's probably more
he's enjoying it more because he could
play with other people keep in mind
smooth has only ever really played these
games for a challenge who's not allowed
to have a co-op assistant uh
and i think that you're seeing smooth
enjoy this game because you can have
access to that like keep them
kid smooth is playing this game and he's
not being paid to do it like
every day he's playing this game and
more sales means more funding for
another project but you know we might
get dlc to the elden ring that wasn't
originally anticipated because maybe
they
i i don't know if they expected eldon
ring to do this good
like maybe they thought they had
something good but they've made a lot of
really good games but this one this one
this one's this one's hitting different
sitting different for sure so
tell me
exactly when it comes to eldon ring
how you think it would
you think the developers could do to
make everyone happy
like and that you don't think that would
hurt the overall foundation of the front
software games uh keep
to keep doing what they're doing let me
be honest with you i feel like like
it's going to finish what you're saying
i was going to say keep doing what
they're doing um if you are going to
have a co-op mode and it don't make it
so difficult that's what i was going to
say
i feel like
yeah
i feel like
what's what's the problem
in just having an invite system
what's the problem just letting people
play the game i mean maybe it's like a
technical issue not necessarily like the
way they do things because i don't know
if you've really played it but if you
venture off too far
like a big white smoke will show up and
you can't go any further
like that's what happens when you have
another person with you like eventually
like it doesn't like there's pretty good
boundaries that you can go but sooner or
the invite later is too annoying for no
reason like at all no reason and let's
just
let's just
tidy that up a little bit i do feel like
i know i'm probably the the minority of
this but i do feel like there needs to
be a little bit more ui interaction with
this not necessarily with what's going
on on the screen but i feel like
okay hear me out when you
in other games on a map
the map can be bland but when you buy
certain
like certain things in the stores it
starts showing you where stuff is on the
map i do feel like something like that
because i just get annoyed i can't find
something i found you know what i'm
saying like man i know this was here
somewhere in this general area and i get
it
they they want you to
adventure but i already i already i
already ventured already traveled
already found it
you want me to go find it again
like
and they're like oh you can mark but the
thing is like
they're all like i don't like the
marking system because they all glow one
color blue
like let me change it to it unless
there's a way to change it which you
know i'm sure the chat will correct me
if there is a way to change it but it's
just like i just want that to change a
little bit just a little bit not like a
whole lot
um i honestly feel like eldon ring
gets a pass when it comes to certain
aspects of the lore like it
people like oh addicts that i don't like
i like the game because there's not a
lot of dialogue
what
so you're okay with going into 18
different dungeons and fighting the same
three or four enemies and i'm sure some
i have fought in like eight different
types of of
giants golems that's in these dungeons
that have no lore to them whatsoever
is someone just locking these things in
these dungeons
like
and i get it that's the point of the
game but it's just like to me they only
put these things in the game to give you
a boss to fight and to patent out the
actual game they didn't put it in their
eye and people like oh addict you know
what it doesn't need that kind of lord
doesn't need explanation to why
everything's there i'm not asking for
everything but when i go through some of
these dungeons and they have a cool boss
at the end i kind of want to know why
he's there you know what i'm saying like
it it's kind of frustrating a little bit
that like i give my opinion on the
matter and people attack me over it they
say look
the from software community some of the
biggest gatekeeping i've ever seen in my
life you know
this is how the front saw i'm part of it
this is how they are you walk in they
got their own rules right as long as you
abide to the from software rules into uh
to their community guidelines they're
some of the most helpful people you've
ever met but the moment you go against
them and the moment you start breaking
they rules they gonna come after you
they come after your net
well
i well i can't speak to that i can't
really speak to that but i think what i
will say is not everything does need a
story i mean
i always i find it all find it odd that
y'all is that community will always know
so much if i guarantee you this if from
felt as though it was important they
would have went ahead and put it
together they would have found a way to
implement it in the story if they felt
that it was important
but everything don't need
i don't even know why the in sakura why
the chained ogre is chained do that make
sense
and i get that
and that's valid criticism but i do feel
like there are certain bosses that that
look really cool and they they do a good
job in certain explanations why certain
bosses you'll fight and you go back to
the round table and they're like you
bought you beat this boss and some will
even give you gifts for it because i
guess they hated that man but
it's just like i wanted more of that
in world building in general not just
related to the main story of the game
like they they have good narrative
focused stuff on here but for just a
part of me just does not like the
concept of just random bosses in these
in these taverns and you don't feel like
there's anything building up for that to
be done like there's cons there's mad
cities not cities but there's towns
that's abandoned shacks abandoned and i
i feel like they could have built more
to a narrative of what's going on with
these towns like why are they abandoned
you know what i'm saying
well okay um we got a comment from the
chat shout out to jonathan dockery he
said there's another ping system that's
green plus symbols so i'm not sure
but there is i didn't see a green one i
don't i haven't really used the ping
system too much that that me this is me
just nitpicking really but i'm still
nitpick like i i enjoy the game i put
like
like 90 plus hours in the game i love
the game but i ain't
what
wait have you finished it no
oh my oh my god i don't even think i'm
half voices okay
all right
this could i be just going i'll be just
getting sidetracked man i spent like 40
minutes in in these in this in this like
castle with all these hands i kid you
not like physical hands that like crawl
around it's creepy
uh but you know it's it's a good game
man uh here's the question to you hustle
amount of
good grace this game is getting do you
think this is going to get games of the
year
yeah
i think so um
if god award doesn't come out this year
if zelda doesn't come out this legend is
out of breath go while two don't come
out this year
um i think a lot would have to happen
but this wouldn't be the first time that
the souls games that released in march
had one game of the year sakura did it i
think that was 2019.
that 19. i can't remember but i know
second row did it and also another game
that one game of the year in march was
the legend of zelda breath of the wild
and
i don't know if it's just me but that
game was these two games are getting a
lot of comparisons breath of the wild
and um
eldon ring for whatever reason they're
getting a lot of competit because the
open world thing i think eldon ring is a
by far better game than the breath of
the wild i mean hey i'm not no nintendo
cat man but i see a lot of people making
that comparison oh and for the record
y'all just just because y'all know
they're doing it for clicks they're not
doing it for nothing else the only thing
that them just might have have in common
is
literally like the open world the fact
that it's open why does everything have
to be open world compared to
to breath of the wild like it's like
i think they compared it to breath of
the wild as opposed to grant a grant i
thought it was because of the because of
what you're doing in the game yeah you
are actually fighting bosses and stuff
like that hey do you make a food in this
game like for like health i know you get
those little uh not canisters what's
those things
those little goblets that you have for
your health and your magic you can do
crafting i don't know if you can make
like physical food i've never tried but
you couldn't cross you couldn't make
food oh okay i don't know if you can you
might be able to because there are stuff
like that that would make you think you
can but i didn't really look into that
kind of mechanic because here's the
thing about like
this particular game is like
they don't really teach you a lot in
terms of mechanics so if you miss it you
miss it like
i wanted to bring that up too um when i
when i streamed that day i missed the cr
i missed the area too by the crafting
kit and and there's a woman
i don't i'm not aware this woman's name
but right before you hit that first
well
after you if you run past the guy on
that big horse and the golden armor you
can run past him but there's like a
church or something that you can go to
there's a
lady on top of like a castle like thing
yeah
yeah
apparently you you're supposed to catch
her in the very beginning of the game
and if you don't you won't see her until
halfway through or like toward the end
of the game if you don't catch her right
away and she's supposed to be helpful um
like i said when i play i have missed
that completely and um
when eric and yourself when y'all did
help me through it it was like no hustle
go back here for it quick because that's
that's where i found the craft because
she was gone
yeah she wasn't there yeah whoever that
woman was wasn't there so if i make it
through that game i'll see her later i
guess but
yeah um
and breath of the wild slaughter both oh
hey hey hey no horizon slaying there in
the chat i want to mention that too
your poor horizon [ __ ] this is twice
that that had that's twice man that's
twice that that happened the horizon um
the horizon series
whose fault is that though who's your
fault is that
i mean can you really get married
the first the first time it wasn't it's
playstation's fault why did they release
this
they they they should gave a lot i mean
i would have gave it like a month before
eldon ring came out it was like what a
couple days
like look like a week i think it's like
a week yeah
and what's funny
what's funny is i bet you when god of
war comes out breath of the wild is
about to draw
well hey um god of war had the same
issue that horizon had i can guarantee
you that one well
you could easily get over shadow by
breath of the wild
uh i'm not rolling i'm not rolling i
know that that people you know the
industry has like uh
that big nostalgia boner or whatever for
for zelda i get it
i'll do nah that's one of the big dogs
i hear what happened with uncharted it
wouldn't happen with the uncharted
series it wouldn't happen like if those
games dropped at the same time man we
know what hey i'm saying blue today boy
that's how i feel that's how i feel
about it no i think i think you
underestimate god of war when it comes
to breath of the wild too
i i think if uh i don't think there's a
lot that can compete with that game at
this point as long as you know nintendo
does a good job developing that gamer
they don't mess up too much
i think that that's gonna be a clean
sweep that game comes out
around anything it's gonna absorb all
the attention
we'll see we'll see if it dropped this
year and something else dropped
we'll see about it but um right now as
it stands though i think um
almost said sakura good lord shame on me
i think elder ring i think elder ring
takes a takes home game of the year i
never seen the front software game like
reportedly do that good though like it
was like a million people in like a week
this this game's going to sell probably
15 to 20 million in the first couple
months like that's how good this game is
doing to do a million on steam already
that's crazy so
all right well we've talked a lot about
old and ring on the uh on the podcast
i'm sure the uh the chat wants let's
let's talk about
this metacritic
article this morning did you see this
saying that no xbox
is the 2021 highest metacritic studios
out there yeah they beat sony they beat
they beat everyone last year uh let me
send you the link but pretty much what
it what it says is that xbox like all of
their games last year like average
is the best rated
developer
or publisher i guess you would say
publisher best rated publisher out last
year
uh so how you feel about this because
like
i mean what what came out last year for
playstation
oh
don't give me the line okay so wait
eamon tones came out last year i know
spider-man
miles morales came out last year
maternal came out last year actually
that's a good year and microsoft beat
all that and keep in mind a lot of these
games reviewed high
like in the high 80s
85 plus if i remember right 85 and up um
damn
yeah i'm surprised uh i i do want to see
that article wherever you gonna put it
in the chat or you're gonna put it
looking for it right now
just i'm
i'm kind of surprised by that
yeah they uh
they i guess they in the past couple
years
they've been like
keeping up with all of them like who
does this and who did that
and yeah it said they're clear as day
that xbox was the number one leading
thing it's hard to find anything now
because this playstation now
uh this playstation state of play is
completely dominated the uh
twitter
that's all i see is talking about these
horrible games that they just announced
i'm joking i'm joking
are you straight you're straight why are
you looking for that um i'm gonna answer
a question or a comment about gamer by
choice
yes
yes you are sir
it's nintendo at least for the terms of
nostalgia you know check it out but
you know look nintendo now
they
look i think they're just focused on
locking people up man they're making
examples out of everybody who emulate
their games and try to sell their games
and
look that's i think that's what they
focused on um breath of the wild two is
gonna have to hit because the people
that they're locking up
excuse me the people that they're
locking up man like i don't know it just
seemed like kind of weak hey
i'm not sure if you know but um
kirby
the new kirby game which i blanked on
the name that's supposed to come out i
think next week or in two weeks
so i'm kind of i'm kind of looking
forward to that actually switch i'm not
the biggest you know
switch fan in general but i will say
switch has a really good year like they
have a good year coming up i can't deny
that
all right so there's the article i just
sent it to you
so it just pretty much says that sony
had two playstation had one uh sony had
two xbox had one i mean
i feel like this is a this is just the
opening thing because if you look at it
microsoft um they had
uh psychonauts
they had flight simulator because that
was a cons i don't know why they would
consider different they had
they had halo which was like an 8687 i
can't remember what did halo eventually
end up settling on metacritic
um i'm not sure i thought it hit around
at 85.87 87.87 okay so
it it it's it's interesting man because
it's like i said you got
even eternal did go didn't it
um
medical eternal got an 86
yeah
yeah
yeah see that's what i surprising
because those games average around that
they were averaging around
84 to like 87. i remember miles morales
hit like at 85. i'm like and that well
deserved by the way well deserved but
ratchet and clank roof to par 88.
what else came out last year for them
um
[Music]
and i said that was that no that was
hold on what dropped last year for play
i know return did come out and then
ratchet came out
um demon souls and
what was that that spider-man game that
came out beforehand that came out like
the year prior so i think we're in here
two now or year three i think but i
don't know if they consider demon souls
part of it or not
i just i just i say demon souls because
it's not on um
just because it's not on xbox on
nintendo
maybe well they may not consider it
though
um
would they consider
definite part of that
you know what i
because that is a bethesda game and
bethesda was on that list too
um you know i know what they were so i
think i'm about to hit the top five okay
no they're number five actually
yeah they actually had a good year last
year too
it's it's an interesting thing man like
i i feel like we're going to see this
going
forward maybe not this year i think this
year might be a little a little light
i don't know we'll have to see how red
phil or red fall or whatever that game
is called let's see how that is
starfield's coming out gran turismo is
coming not grand true uh uh
we got uh forza motorsports that's
coming out
probably gonna have a couple games
sprinkled in in there so we're gonna see
those type of games i'm sure microsoft
has some kind of arrangements made with
certain
developers probably getting like a year
time to exclusivity so i have to see
that is like but last year they had age
of empire like 83-84 they had a really
good year last year
okay i can explore well i see your next
explanation now because i kind of forgot
what came out with uh with xbox what
they put out earlier but i can see why
they're number one now um four to five
four to horizon five which you know
that's like nineteen two ninety
yep yep psychonauts recycle knives was
kind of sold after um flight simulator
to help that a whole lot that's on 92.
yup and then hello infinite so they
they've had titles and they had age of
empire
uh yes yep i mean they had a very fair
amount but you know hey
plus i'm sure i'm sure they'll use gears
tactics when they re-release it for the
xbox
um that i don't see in this article but
i'm sure i'm i'm sure they did that
that's good man like you know it's good
competition like one of the things that
we need to see more is this type of
competition we need to see
microsoft and sony fighting
more high quality titles like regardless
how you feel about some of the games
they're they're high quality titles you
know if you play psychonauts you know
that was a title that took a lot of time
effort and money into uh just because it
wasn't your type of game doesn't mean
it's a game that other people aren't
gonna like
uh but there ain't a lot of whole a
whole lot to talk about that so you know
let's move on because it's gonna be a
kind of a light show because obviously
there ain't a lot of talk about it's
kind of been dead for information hustle
oh addict hey can i throw a topic in
here too sure um i saw you did i saw you
did the video on perfect dark earlier
this week can we speak on that oh you
talking about it might be at e3
that's right that's right that's right
is it sad i don't care about perfect
dark at all yes yes yes it is it is well
nostalgia you know touches mine so okay
okay okay okay so okay here we go hustle
sell me on perfect dart right now
so you want perfect dark right now uh
well okay so you're already like first
person games because you play halo over
gears so you already like the first
person aesthetic
um
i think you're more of a sci-fi cat i
could be wrong but you do play destiny
and that that's not exactly based in
realism so i'll say there's a definite
there's definitely a sapphire element to
it so explain the sci-fi element to me
explain the sci-fi element to me for for
perfect art why is it make it sci-fi
i've i don't know nothing about perfect
art
okay cool so if it's gonna stay true to
the actual story if perfect duck is
gonna stay true to the story and it's
gonna be a spiritual reboot like we do
believe it is
joanna dark is she works either works
with a company called data down and you
put me on the spot i already did a video
about this but
there's a lot of futuristic stuff going
on going on in there
what's up big cloud thank you for that
donation we we appreciate you too homie
listen
you can run around with an alien called
elvis if this is going to be the
spiritual so there's aliens in perfect
dark
oh dawg there's aliens there's guns
that'll shoot through walls
don't put that in the multiplayer by the
way i did a video on that once upon a
time don't put that in the multiplayer
there are a lot of like different
weapons yo there's a gun called the
laptop gun that you could throw like as
you know you can hit all all the guns
have like secondary
controls so like on souvenir or 64 is
you would do like the whole day and
press b and with the laptop gun in
particular it'll turn itself into a
turret so so you got a group of guys
coming around the corner you're having
trouble with
just lay them all down it's a turret you
lay them all down you know it's it's a
whole lot to go with that the story is
cool too and um
that was like the first time you saw
like a
well what second time for me because uh
tomb raider was out to out then too but
just a lot of the
stuff that happens i don't want to say
it's wacky because it's not like see if
these types of wacky
it's
it'll it's not as serious as like rise
of the tomb raider not doing a good job
of selling me on this song
you won't play it you're gonna enjoy it
sir also and i don't know if they're
gonna add this but um that's another
game that had a co-op campaign too so i
don't know if they're going to add that
but back in the day i had co-op campaign
my brother used to play it all the time
but you know what you should have opened
that with hustle
what's up you should be like oh why do
you want to play
that's how i would like addict
you know this i could tell you
about the story about aliens about some
sci-fi but all i got to say is that it's
on game pass okay gustle i get it
i mean
hey look i ain't for the whole i'm from
about that day one though i gotta buy
that one day one even if i don't play
like a physical version of it
i gotta get like the xbox here i'll
probably just have it up on the manual
man um we got a two dollar super chat
from big cloud gaming shout out to you
sir we see what you about to do in a
couple days
salute to the homies well thank you very
much kansai you know we appreciate you
hey if you're not subscribed to big
cloud and you are a fan of
a certain professional wrestler i'll
just say
go ahead and subscribe to big cloud now
i believe that interview's coming out
tomorrow i believe that interview is
coming out tomorrow and do a little
promo for big cloud
if you do youtube he has another uh
interview coming up i'm not sure what
day but he has with the
people who can help you end youtube with
the vidiq
big cloud don't kill me but i know you
tweeted it out so that's why i'm that's
why i'm talking about it big homie um
congratulations to you um
hey y'all let me know in the chat cause
i saw somebody that would comment
you said um my excitement was infectious
listen perfect dark is that good let me
let me tell you all that let me tell you
all that and i hope that the initiative
don't mess it up
should should me and addict run the
difference co-op because i i kind of
want to run it if it's co-op better i'm
gonna buy them on steam man i kind of
feel like we should run into this co-op
seriously if it's cross-play sure but i
ain't touching that steam store
and i ain't touching it at all like that
if it's if it's called but you know you
hopefully maybe you have an xbox series
s at that time you know maybe you'll
have one of these consoles
you get serious x man i can't
you could just get you could just get
this game pass so we could play it on
xbox you don't i can't i got it on pc i
got game plans on pc actually i still
pay for it yup i still still pay for i
gotta pay depths don't oh we're gonna we
getting sidetracked my fault i got to
play depth's door i still got game pads
on pc i got to play deaf store all right
so
let's go and talk about this bungie
thing i don't know if you saw this did
you see people were sharing
apparently
it's
hot that
bungie's hiring for third person games
why no i didn't see that yeah but full
i mean listen listen i would like to
think i had some credit
in you know in making this move because
they probably heard me when i was on
here with you and i said hey they got
too many first-person games but i i
think anybody can see that anybody and
all of us can see that there are too
many first-person games i think that's
cool if they
are hiring one for third person stuff
wait hold on you said bungie or
yeah bungie oh you said punji i'm i'm
thinking about halo
no bungie bungie's hiring
for third person stuff now obviously
this doesn't mean anything
for all we know this could literally
just be
you know them making like something
related third person doesn't necessarily
make they're making an entire third
person game
but
it's interesting because
sony buys them
and then two weeks later they're hiring
for third person
talent
well
um they have a lot of ips that well one
op one ip in particular that i do want
to see make a comeback
was the game by made by ready at dawn
that was the order 1886.
i kind of was like gears on playstation
if we really keep if we really want to
take it there so like that i think
that's dope that um that they're doing
this um i'm assuming that this won't be
a multi platinum this will be on
playstation and um you know that's what
they do over there playstation that that
third person greatness man
over the shoulder
kratos
nathan drake chloe frazier goodness
listen i i'm here for that i'm here for
that because as y'all know i prefer
third person over first person i'd
rather see my character than
this is why i can't connect with master
chief i know i'm trying to slam to
nobody
and i was just going on about perfect
dog uh attic i'll take you to a trip
down memory road with you right quick
there was a long time ago
to where we thought the coalition was
going to work on perfect dark i said
cool you know why because joanna joanna
dark and third person that's dope to me
like i would love to see more of that
and obviously that's not going to happen
now
we i like third person good for bungie
and you know what honestly like they do
first person so well i i got a feeling
they're going to knock the third person
thing out the park
oh man i'm not too
i hope because i i do
i don't know if they're making a third
person game
uh i
i'm kind of worried about that because i
mean they're making three games
and it's kind of interesting because
that means they're making project matter
destiny and whatever this game is
now that doesn't necessarily mean that
this is the third
person game like it could literally just
be something they need for matter but
i'm pretty sure it's probably the latter
because at the end of the day they go
from
making first-person stuff exclusively
just about and then they get bought by
sony now they're hiring third-person
stuff so we'll have to see how that is i
like like i said man they ain't a lot
going on right now uh first off we'll
take about 10 15 minutes just you know
just
[ __ ] around we'll answer some
questions in the chat too uh you know to
tell you guys my ambitions make goals
it's like you know
things been going pretty good with the
attic show i do appreciate uh you know i
know it's been kind of
inconsistent and reconsistent because uh
first off i blame witch queen
entirely i missed the week because the
witch queen i know i could have had that
show but
you guys know if i would have had that
show it would have been me wanting to
end the show so it's just best for me to
end the show
you know it's it's nice like you know uh
probably here in the next maybe month
now next month we i am going to pax east
so i don't know if
i'll be here
at the end of that month let me see
if i am i'm gonna be tired
because that's when i get back
i i don't know i don't expect for you to
do that end the show and cut now i
wouldn't expect that no way
i mean
we'll just see we'll have to see how i
feel man maybe i'm gonna
be mad energetic i don't know uh right
now it's like i said i am uh
playing and reviewing
triangle strategy
i wish this i need to figure out how to
actually work this camera you know that
and it like actually worked this camera
all right so let's let's have a little
behind the scenes uh do you have it in
manual focus or do you have an autofocus
i don't know we'll figure that out later
i actually had someone send me a video
uh so that's like next week's tackle
like it it works fine now as long as i'm
talking but if i put anything in front
of the screen it's like nah nah
you probably have it in manual focus
because i can do the
wait you're talking manual
i said man you won't focus
look here look at it
look look at the the
the
the confidence you had when you put that
up in the uh on the screen i'm trying to
show you okay y'all see hey well that's
that's my light you know i never mind
just know that there's a difference
between auto focus and manual focus my
camera is stationary i got a ring light
around this thing now this is why i'm so
well lit
you won't
if i wanted to show y'all something and
i wanted to put an auto focus it would
every time i moved this was the same
thing that was happening in the king he
would go in and out of focus he would
blur in him laurel and i think that's
what you may have in manual focus and i
think that's why you probably couldn't
show that game the way you wanted to but
that's just me that's just me i mean
i'll look at it later like yeah the
thing is is like i'm excited about the
return on thing
if it is oh yeah i did see people in the
comment section saying that uh they said
full
campaign if that is true i'll probably
play that
what they did um actually and well i
think i was ahead of you at that point
but i was like oh wait i said i can
finally get some help because they said
it was the full campaign thing and also
and we mentioned that earlier well i
mentioned that earlier
it looks like it's going to answer some
questions
for that ending i don't know if people
was just quote unquote dissatisfied i
didn't beat the game i saw that and then
i was just a little confused by the
multiple endings it had but i think it
answers those questions as well and
i'm actually cool with that like
normally right
normally when it comes to making a
single play game like that i would like
for you to get it and knock it out the
park the first time around however since
this update is free and you can get this
game for like
oh i'm sure you can catch it on sale i'm
sure you can catch this game on sale if
you haven't played it and you like a
tough game like that we were talking
about um ellen ring and everything
i feel like you should give a horizon
horizon
pardon me my fault gorilla i mean that
i feel like you should get return a
little shot i feel like everyone feels
like you should
trade too young game pass day one
that that samurai movie that samurai
game that was at the playstation
showcase
are you saying that they said it's day
one
if that's day one that that looks bad
like you you have a day one game
and microsoft you you have a game on
your showcase and microsoft announces in
the same day that is coming to their
platform in game pass
hey addict want to keep it real with
your dog
that don't matter no more i'm a and i
kind of want to make a video about this
too that whole competition thing you
remember when phil spencer and it's not
the harking back to that remember when
the that acquisition came with
activision he was like yo um playstation
not our competition you know he was
talking about amazon and
you know google et cetera et cetera we
talked about the real big players like
uh
embracer group and all them he was
talking about them he wasn't talking
about playstation so
you saying that whoever put that in the
chat
it wouldn't surprise me if that is true
because it hasn't been confirmed yet but
that wouldn't surprise me anyways i
think that those days are over i think
that what we i think the bigger shock
would be like a god of war like one of
those first
first party titles going over there like
we saw with um
the baseball game that everybody seems
to love so much we saw with that and
like that was like a shocking thing that
would be shocking but that that game
that they showed and i mentioned earlier
they was going to show nothing in these
a lot of indie stuff anyway so at least
in third party so
i'm cool with that that's that's not a
thing
i i kind of hope not that it would be
but i hope the the the cowabunga
collection is over there game fast i'm
not gonna lie i'm not gonna lie
don't do it though just out of curiosity
hustle how do you feel about this year's
like e3 time like do you think people
like microsoft and them are going to
show up pretty heavy do you think
microsoft's going to have a good e3 this
year
i feel like we should see like a vowel
apparently perfect art's probably going
to be there
i think with every i think with
everything that's going on yeah
absolutely i think i'm gonna be real
with you i think microsoft's next five
e3s are gonna be good like next five e3
yo you we we saw hold on
we got to put this
let's let's go back a little bit when
when they started acquiring all these
studios before the um activision deal
before that before that we saw like the
rollout and one of the things that i
always constantly preach while i'm on
here is like yo
they finna have a nice little 22 uh 2023
2024 2025.
now with the this acquisition of of
activision
that's got us a tongue twister now when
we see stuff like that it's the role of
it's just getting bigger it's like the
snowball is rolling downhill and it's
getting bigger and bigger um i feel like
they definitely gonna live up to it
they're gonna live up they're gonna live
up to the hype man i think they are
because they literally have something
for everybody and i want to make this
xbox thing i don't wanna make i don't
wanna you know
i don't wanna believe green anybody we
supposed to be talking about
playstations and everything else but go
ahead daddy go ahead to be honest like
when it comes to
exactly how this conference is supposed
to go
they're gonna have to start doing more
things like like a direct style because
they got too much to show now they got i
mean obviously call of duty's gonna have
to be at every conference now from now
on like just because
you know that might be a multiplied
that's being announced on a xbox stage
from here on out
uh you know maybe after this marketing
goes up that's when it'll start being
shown and then after the that you know
that's going to take a lot of time just
showing that and then you're going to go
off of overwatch diablo there's a lot of
stuff they have to show at their
conferences and so that's why i feel
like you know
um
i feel like they should bring inside
xbox back but they need to they need to
actually hire influencers to direct the
show and not because like i said it all
i said it on a show i was on a couple
days ago where it was just like look
like
right now the biggest issue we have
inside xbox it was pr people trying to
talk to us
we don't want to hear from pr people we
don't want to talk to pr people pr
people is literally the opposite of what
influencers like talking to because pr
people would talk around every question
you have
so it's just what well i i didn't want
to just give a special shout out to um a
young lady that big cloud had
interviewed him in blaze over there on
my rgt podcast
hopefully friend of the show and
hopefully she'll come over here one day
uh kate nager she um i found kate yeager
through uh inside xbox i found it
charlie though through inside xbox
i kind of feel like
okay remember how you you just said they
needed to hire more influences right
i think so i think those two in
particular will work well but you
remember the last time they tried to do
something with um
well i know their names and i'm not
gonna mention them with two other
influences it was two other young ladies
two other young ladies who i follow by
the way and it didn't turn out as well
as it should
because they don't they didn't have any
type of history with any of the games
that were showing they kind of didn't
know what was going on et cetera et
cetera um i'm not gonna mention that
name just because i don't want i don't
want them to think that i'm taking the
crap on them but i feel like if you are
going to get people
they can get you off of that like they
can get
lp they can get a weapon
and that's what i'm saying like that's
what i'm yeah yeah we i think we get
somebody who would it with it like that
i think the biggest issue
when it comes to stuff like
like these type of events like inside
xbox is like look major nelson's cool
and but major nelson i don't really feel
like
he knows how to interact with people i
don't think he knows how to talk to the
to our audience you know what i'm saying
like it's just like when you make these
type of events
you don't make these events
for casual audience you make these
events for the hardcore audience because
they're the ones watching your event now
e3 that's different a little bit
different and i feel like it's still
around the same type of laws when it
comes to e3 but it's just like they got
to do better i don't think inside xbox
was the issue that people running inside
xbox was the issue because i i honestly
truly feel like when it come to inside
xbox it was just cringy
and there wasn't
but see it was long and there wasn't a
lot of substance either there was a lot
of talking for no reason like you could
do both you could show me gameplay and
you could talk at the same time uh you
don't need to bring people on multiple
times i remember there was a inside xbox
where the same people come on twice
like it's just like look inside xbox can
come back maybe you should rename it at
this point because people
have have such a bad taste when it comes
to inside xbox you have the exact same
formula just shorten it and actually
have your games in it stop giving your
games to the video game awards stop
giving your games all around anyone
without that's willing to show in a
microsoft conference and show it there
hey this is how they need to do they
need to have like they need inside xbox
at the beginning of the year
and that's for like the first couple
months they need to have uh then they
have e3 around july august then they
have another uh inside xbox around the
video around the uh uh
gamescom around that area and then they
have xo at the end of the year
yeah but uh you know why i disagree with
part of that you said don't give it to
the game awards but yo every year that
the game awards has been in existence
whether we are keen on that show or not
i'm not saying that i'm not and i'm not
saying that you're not but whether the
general public is you know good on that
show on that the ratings go up every
time the ratings like increase like by a
lot every single year so look i ain't
gonna hold you if i got like
um
a perfect dark announcement right if i
got a uh that elder ring what's his name
um
with the crazy girl hellblade if i got a
hellblade announcement if i got
something like that yo they they
revealed the console
at the game
like see
and i get that i get that
but also when a playstation
big event happens like their showcase
does the whole industry not stop
the whole industry tunes in and people's
like oh they're bigger no because
playstation is known for keeping their
stuff for them when you watch a
playstation showcase you expect great
stuff because they're keeping their best
stuff for them
but when you watch an xbox showcase you
don't know
because
you got you know
a variety of events that could pop in at
any time you got the game awards that
they could show something there like
it's like imagine that they would have
held
the hellblade gameplay they showed at
the video game awards last year it
showed it at their own e3 stage it would
have made the show better
yeah yeah but you know but sometimes you
got to take the laws in order to like to
get the big w yeah but
you gotta you know you're never gonna
win the world you're never gonna build
that anticipation that hype
unless you start doing it
because now people don't now when people
watch an xbox show they like okay it's
cool but let's let's keep our
expectations in check because we don't
know if they're gonna show this year we
don't know if they could show this there
we know that they have deliberately held
stuff to show it at the video game
awards so you can automatically assume
that there's a chance they might do that
again we know that they don't really
generally have xos right now because of
the um the pandemic which that might
change it's probably going to change but
it's just like
you have all of these titles 30 plus
studios you just bought activision you
have all of this
what i want to see
is you start using these titles to
building your own show portfolios when i
see an inside xbox you can do all the
crazy stuff just have relevant stuff
there that we're going to want to hear
from i'll be sure you can bring in your
third party stuff like imagine the
showcase that they have would stay to
play when they dedicated to a certain
game they could have inside xbox
dedicating to perfect dark in-depth
stuff on the gameplay dedicating it to
about in-depth stuff on the gameplay
like they can have stuff like that but
the thing is you're never going to build
true hype for these events when you're
constantly giving your best stuff like
hustle
hustle they showed their next console on
another man stage
hey hey hey but also also addict they
had to do that
before before all of this happened y'all
know what they was coming up off of they
had to create such positive i'm gonna
say pr but maybe it is pr they had to
create such positive promotion for the
the series consoles that were coming out
they had to do that and also let's be
real were there like 20 million people
watching that joint
and i get that like okay i i can
understand the xbox series x and the
hellblade announcement i can understand
that to a point hang on you just came
off a generation of getting your teeth
bashed in you you got to turn this you
got to turn this around hey my dog is
going off right now hold on okay okay
look look chad i see what you guys are
saying man i see they don't have a lot
to show all i'm saying is
if you start building stuff up and you
force people to come to you for these
events
people are going to be hyped now i'm not
saying that they don't have good events
felt like last year's is a solid great
event all i'm saying is
what the hellblade gameplay would have
been at e3 it would have been a way
better show
you know
i just personally feel like
they need to do better on their own
stage now sure maybe right now they're
doing it because they have to build a
portfolio that the build trust back into
the gamers they're coming off a pretty
you know average
generation so maybe that's the reason
they're doing it but are we going to say
this forever
i mean it's like i said they showed
their brand new system on another person
stage sure i can understand why they did
that and the reason i could understand
why they did that is because they wanted
to generate a lot of hype going into
next generation showing the xbox series
x and hellblade at
the
video game awards made sense
but if they would have showed that at xo
a couple months earlier that would have
made sense too
sure what i've had is
hold up it wouldn't have had as many
people
but everyone would have been writing it
as the xo everyone would have been
writing it as
their stuff
and sure i do think
it being announced that the video game
awards worked better for them in terms
of
having more eyes on it i don't think it
did better than as far as their brand
itself
and i was reading the chat i was reading
chat all right
okay
i mean
look i i always look at it like this man
if
if i have something
that big to announce and i know what the
reception's gonna be no matter how big
it is and we're not popping right now
but i have another opportunity to
announce it let's say oh on my own
channel right i don't have as many subs
as the ilp channel but if i got
something to announce i'll probably do
it over here because there's a lot more
people watching sometimes you got to
take the l in order to get the big w
that's that's just how i feel about it
but i feel you know but you at some
point and you are right at some point
they are going to have to build
anticipation brick by brick for their
own thing at a certain point they are
they can still work with the you know
the other guys that are with the game
award and that that's all i'm saying
like i'm not saying they have to do it
all i'm saying
is
i do sense that anticipation that hype
train the moment playstation announces a
showcase
the internet just turns the hell over
and i'm not saying that xbox doesn't get
that same treatment they do but i do
know that there's a lot of times where
i'll be watching these podcasts and
people will ask them do you think this
is going to be there it's like no i
think that might be at the video game
awards and it's just like
i get it
video game awards is growing but at the
same time
xbox is your stuff you don't see
playstation announcing big ass stuff at
the video game awards you don't see
nintendo announcing big-ass stuff at the
video game awards like they got to do
better on building their own portfolio
at their own events because now when
you're going with 30 plus studios
you gotta have better
outputs
to reveal information and to talk about
games because right now
they don't really have an inside xbox we
haven't seen one in a while
they don't have anything direct style
they got e3 in the video game awards
and you need to start building a
portfolio
to show your own outlets and stuff and i
think that starts with
keeping the majority of your good stuff
off other people's show
hey
i do want to say something too
the inside xbox thing ah
how you how you had pitched that idea
you know initially that's what i thought
was going to happen like if they had
like a big
let's say perfect dog right would just
you know just pull that game at the sky
if they had a perfect dock if they had a
halo i always assume that you know a lot
of a few other things may have been
announced but the focus would be on this
thing you know that instead of doing
that inside xbox for halo if i remember
right they just did like a lot they did
like a youtube premiere or something
like that now i'm sure the pandemic had
a lot to do with that but do you
remember what i'm talking about because
i remember when they did that that
morning they had dropped like a video on
halo's multiplayer yeah i don't
right so i'm like for them not to have
uh inside xbox or something like that
that's a that's a mess that that is a
mess because it's not nowhere else and
you're something that you're already
doing but i guess you know again it's
because of the pandemic stuff in the
word you couldn't do it but i think you
know
i know what i think i'm almost sure that
things will turn around and uh i do want
to say this you know additionally when
we started this conversation this
portion of the podcast we were supposed
to be talking about what's what was
going on with the future plans
we're getting really good
we got a ten dollar super from jay uh cj
mike 1024 loving the show added console
have good chemistry big big ups from
texas i appreciate it man uh appreciate
the support now look like i feel like
inside xboxes you use that to break down
games
uh e3 you use that for a road map like
kind of what happens uh 2024 2025 and xo
you use
to show what's happening next year
and that's how i mean obviously they're
going to do what they're going to do and
it's going to be fine regardless because
we've clearly seen that microsoft
they're they're on a better branching
path and that's one of the biggest
criticism i have left for them is just
do a better job
at your own stuff you don't necessarily
have to pull everything off the video
game awards
but you know gameplay stuff show that at
the video game awards but don't reveal
brand new games there you know what i'm
saying because especially something as
big as like
is like
you know
a fable gameplay reveal or something
like that like
that kind of stuff like compulsions next
game that better not be at a video game
awards that's got to be on their stage
that's their game
that's that's the only real criticism i
have and i think they're in a lot better
place than they used to be and i think
they're gonna do well um you know this
thing with 2021 being their highly
year of xbox i think that's just
starting i think you're going to start
seeing that a lot and it's not going to
be necessarily because they have the
better uh the better games it's good
because they have the most consistent
good games hey gotta stop you shout out
to stone patrol in the chat and i do
want to google this um
they said the gamer was had 85 million
people watching it and that's cool
that's cool but you're never going to
get them
but but how much did the last
playstation event get the showcase
it was 85 million it was a lot i bet you
it was a lot it might not have been 85
million but i bet you it was a lot
i think i think when i i think when i
was watching that live there was like
700 and some thousand people watching it
live
not pre-recorded not live
yeah but this is still you know like you
just have the opportunity to reach more
people i think what the what you want to
do is cool but honestly it's more like
you know the xbox fan is going to watch
it i mean hell i'm going to watch it
because i kind of watch everything and i
know somebody in chat said that too i
can't watch every i'm guilty of that i
watch everything too just to see what's
new and everything um
we got to fight out soup trap from uh
skateless
skate lights i don't know man i
apologize uh xbox should be a should do
state of play because they have too many
games uh ps should have stuck at e2 e3 i
agree i i but see the thing is is
playstation is doing that kind of format
as well and i actually think out of
nintendo direct
state of play
and inside xbox instead of playing
inside a state of play
and um nintendo direct is far better
than inside
so yeah
nintendo they just get to it they don't
waste no time they don't don't throw
nothing stupid in there like they just
not here go
here go here go they they hit you off in
the joint and that's that's how that's
how they do it we got a two dollar trap
from why so serious what's up addict to
hustle
what's up
what's up wife so serious man i gotta go
watch that new batman movie i'm gonna go
watch it friday uh probably next week
sometimes we might have a um
one of those things uh
we might do something for the members
and patrons i don't know we'll see uh it
depends on what i'm doing next week if i
have time to do something like that but
you know
i'm gonna end this show here soon it's
just like look i'm not saying that
they don't do
what's right
i know they have a lot going up they
have they're in a different perspective
than they are with playstation
playstation it's coming off probably one
of the best generations they've ever had
they got that hype they could do
whatever they want i just feel like
it got to get to the point
where they feel confident with showing
their own stuff on their own stage
regardless that they might not hit
that amount of viewership
they still going to
you know if they started doing it and
showing like all that stuff on their
stage the next time xbox has another
event people's like yo it's gonna be
bangers because they've always been
doing it here lightly and then before
you know it they're going to build up
that viewership because people are
starting to trust their shows i'm not
saying people don't watch their shows
i'm sure a lot of people watch their
shows but i'm sure there's a lot of
people that just wait for the ign
the ig and snippets of what happened
you know playstation i don't feel like
have that issue i feel like when i see a
playstation showcase everyone is showing
up for that there's like 40 live streams
and shout out to you guys because uh you
weren't we're
we're a preferred xbox podcast and you
guys uh you definitely help us in the
playstation realm uh but you know
i just want to see better that's all i
just want to see them do some kind of
stay to play thing
uh i want to see more of their stuff on
their stage
if they got to do this for a couple more
years to just generate more hype for
their games and so be it it's really me
nitpicking like i just personally feel
like when you see playstation even know
how average that show we just watched
was we was in there watching the [ __ ] so
you know that's how it is like when it
come to the inside xbox there at the end
we wasn't doing inside xbox because we
knew it wasn't going to be
you know it's going to be subpar and it
was going to be cringy uh i hope i don't
want to say this i want to say this
before we before we wrap up
i googled that the game awards thing
and i thought stone was just joking
around no no um this recent one that
they had or at least 2021 anyway um 85
million global live streams
that's
it's like i said no one no one's denying
their dominance i they they're
definitely doing good but the thing is
is
viewership's great but building your
brand and having brand trust is is good
too
you know i think you want long term not
not not the short term quick it's like
because right now they have 30 plus
studios they need better outlets to show
these and they're gonna have a hard time
having good content if they're giving
away all their content that's all it was
like i get it i'm not gonna say i don't
understand why they don't put stuff on
the video game awards my ass is live
streaming that [ __ ] every year too
so
it's and i
there's a lot of stuff i feel like needs
to change in the video game awards but
it's not horrible
it's it's i think it's too long
i think they need to give more time to
the actual people that's getting the
rewards
but it is what it is the dude's doing
his thing
and he's and he's growing it's all that
matters with the jeff jeff jeff i might
try to i might try to reach out to him
to get him on iop
but anyway
all right so
we're probably in the next couple weeks
we're going to have a developer on i'm
not gonna say who's gonna be yet
uh but
you know he he he he works in a very
prohibited company i'll put it to you
that way
uh so we'll be having him on and uh you
know we're gonna pick his brain a little
bit man we're gonna pick his brain
exactly the the stages of development in
general
and now
when you guys see who it is
i apologize but we can't talk about
certain things
clearly because i don't want him on here
to talk about these games uh these
certain games him himself might have
developed or is developing i want to
have him on here as a developer talking
about the states of making a game
because i feel like there's a lot of
stuff going around that people are
misinformed about i feel like there's a
lot of things that people act like it's
mad easy to do when you don't know
anything about the industry you don't
know how it is to develop and stuff so i
just want to get you know someone on
here just pick their brain apart you
know
if they don't
you know just just get a general
information out of them and i hope you
guys enjoy because i want to do a little
bit more
develop like reviews on here interviews
you know try to get some indie
developers i really enjoy so put in the
comment section you know
a good indie developer game now
try to keep away from bigger stuff
because i do try to save that for iop
obviously
uh i have a lot of connections to a lot
of different people but i don't
i don't want to bring them on until
they're on iop if that makes sense so
you know that's the
yeah that's the big show you gotta yeah
i mean you gotta usher you got usher man
right too so you know i feel that i feel
that yeah so this year
yeah we will be doing
the a prediction show similar to iop
it'll probably be a month before iop is
a prediction show because i want to sep
space them out so we'll probably do it
in reverse like iop starts out usually
with nintendo if we do one this year
with nintendo so we'll probably start
out with xbox that time so we're doing a
reverse so it's not like the same
content
uh but i appreciate everyone coming
through man we're gonna go and end the
show
gotta play more of this little triangle
game you know once again stop focusing
i'm gonna actually switch the stuff
there we go there you go
there we go
now i'm
appreciative for coming through man we
will be back here next tuesday
at 1 p.m nine at 1 pm 5 p.m i don't know
why i said one period all right
we'll be back here at one uh 5 p.m next
week i appreciate you for coming through
might try to get uh an xbox guest on
here next week but
any anything what are you doing hustle
what what is hustle doing my voice is
going out so what are you doing
well after this podcast i got to fix
something in obs to see why i'm not
having any desktop audio i'm a little
concerned i'm a little confused but um i
plan on streaming eldon ring saturday
friday night if i'm lucky
i will play what's that i'm gonna try to
finish uncharted three which
i got my thoughts about that one i like
i like the uncharted series as a whole
but i got my thoughts on uncharted three
for that
it's a bit of a drag i'll just say that
it's a bit of a drag um
so i'm gonna work on that um
for those of you who don't know i kind
of had the opportunity to move some
things from one of my rooms to an office
that i'm sharing this is why you see the
green screen up because boy it's a mess
back there
but
i'm well lit i'm able to put my lights
up and do my thing i'll do a video i'll
probably do a video on like a setup tour
and stuff like that but i've been
working on that too and shout out to you
edit because you've kind of been
understanding because kind of one of the
reasons why i wasn't here last week and
i really couldn't have been here
yesterday because i was still putting
all this stuff together as you know but
thank you for that i appreciate that no
problem man
uh so